STARTING A THREEEEARTING LINEUP
OF YOUR SCREEN, BROUGHT TO YOU
BY TACO BELL. 11
GAMES IN 11 CITIES IN 22 DAYS
INTO THE ZONE, STEVEN STAMKOS.
COULD NOT CONNECT WITH KUCHEROV.
AND SLOTTED IN ON THE THIRD
>> Sean:EST
SHIFT OF THE GAME.
IT'S A TURNOVER AS BOGOSIAN
TRIES TOVATRANO.
BRADEN THISOF HIS STICK AS THE
ATTACK  IN.
SOME SKATING ROOM FOR ROSS
COLTON, BUT THEY'RE IN THE MIDST
OF A LINE CHANGE.
BACK TO TROUBA AT THE POINT AND
POINT DROUGHT OF
CHER
STOPS.
HERE'S THE SECOND ONE OF CERNAK
AS HE SHOOTS IT THROUGH T TTHER.
SHESTERKIN IS ABLE TO JUMP ON IT
BEFORE STAMKOS CAN GET A TWIG ON
IT. TO PLAY IT
CROSS-ICE.
SLID DOWN BY RYAN REAVES.
THIS IS THE FOURT SNAPPED IT RI.
KNOCKED DOWN BY SHESTERKIN AND
HE'S WAITING FOR HIS TEAMMATES
TO CHANGE,,
TR
SERGACHEV, TRIED TO FEED IT DOWN
LOW.
, A ONE-TIMER.
HIT SOME TRAFFIC OUT IN FRONT
AND THEY SCORE! -- INTO THE
BLUE PAPA. LUCKY TO BE DOWN
JUST THE ONE.
HERE THAT.
THE RANGERS WANT TO MAKE SURE
THEY STAY ON TOP OF THEM IN SECT
POINT SQUEAKS IT UNDER THETIONA
GLOVE, YOU
HOWEVER, THESE CALLS ARE ALWAYS
KEEPING INTO THE GAME.
THE COACHING STAFF SAW IT ON
THEIR RECENT ROAD TRIP, THEY
HAVE TO FIGURE IT BOGOSIAN.
KUCHEROV OFF THE WALL.HERE.
PLAYOFF STYLE HOCKEY GAME WITH
ABOUT 20 GAMES TO GO IN THEMIDD
SERGACHEV IN DEEP.
AROUND FOR KILLORN.
SURVEYING.
HAS IT BLOCKED.NDER THE ARM OF .
THE 13th POWER PLAY GOAL OF THE
SE